battlefield hardline comes out tomorrow
and it's already dividing people between
the die-hard fans and those who are
getting a little tired of EA's
annualized shooter which doesn't always
innovate as much as we wish it would if
you fall into that first category have
fun playing battlefield if you're in
that of the category though here are
four cop games that might just be better
or will at least give you the same cops
versus robbers fix now we tried to be
pretty careful to keep the cops and
robbers games and away from cops gone
rogue and detective games so while we
love games like Max Payne Sleeping Dogs
in LA noire we'll save them for another
episode first up we should start with
all great cop game lists start and
that's with swat 4 swat 4 the tactical
FPS that particularly kicks ass made by
the then up-and-coming developer
irrational games the SWAT games were an
offshoot from the police quest adventure
game series and they focused on detailed
and realistic simulations of SWAT team
tactics which had rarely been seen in
games before while SWAT one two and
three were all wildly different genres
of games irrational eventually came in
and perfected the first-person variant
introduced in SWAT 3 with SWAT 4 the
game featured managing a small squad and
taking them through a variety of
real-world missions and all demanding
meticulously planned approaches these
ranged from small-scale domestic
violence situations all the way up to
bank heists as with any good cop game
you can opt for a few different
strategies ranging from the stealthy to
be significantly less stealthy either
way you'll have to pick the right
equipment depending on your tactical
plan so you can take out the bad guys
successfully and keep the civilians safe
then again why take out the bad guys
when you could be the bad guys payday 2
may have muddied morals but the level of
enjoyment you'll have while playing it
is crystal clear payday 2 offers up a
perfect arena for cooperative crime like
SWAT 4 it comes packed with different
kinds of missions and it's up to you and
your core buddies to
side how to approach them although a low
profile stealth approach is entirely
feasible the typical payday to mission
will usually have [ __ ] hitting the fan
pretty quickly
luckily the shooting mechanics are
spot-on and let me tell you you will be
shooting hundreds of cops at any given
moment your performance in payday 2 will
only be as good as your cooperation and
communication skills as a team
though you will spend a lot of time
yelling about drills and contending with
overly jumpy citizens who all have SWAT
on speed-dial
payday 2 is still constantly updated
today with new weapons skills heists and
unexpected crossovers so staying engaged
in this one shouldn't be a problem if
you're feeling a little shortchanged
that this list isn't catering to the
sweet car chases that battlefield
hardline promises I'd offer you turn
your attention to Need for Speed rivals
this open-world racer has you slip into
the shoes of either a heroic cop or a
no-good racer then you put one of those
shoes on a gas pedal and race the [ __ ]
out of each other in gorgeous cars which
will not be so gorgeous when you're
finished with them while playing as a
cop your job is to run the criminals off
the road and as a racer you just want to
get away alive and just in case you're
not the world's greatest driver you'll
have access to tools like spike strips
and jammers to take out your opponents
before you find yourself getting rammed
into the side of a mountain
there are in-depth career tracks for
both options and the multiplayer is
seamlessly integrated into the
single-player map so you never have to
leave your vehicle rivals is a great car
heavy cops-and-robbers alternatives that
has you chasing points and driving fast
whether you're the hunter or the hunted
if you want that SWAT for flavor but
from a game that's a little more modern
then you won't be disappointed by door
kickers from three men studio kill house
games door kickers is a top-down
realtime strategy game where you take
charge of a SWAT team during tactical
interventions and yes you certainly kick
down a lot of doors you'll have to
choose the appropriate gear settle the
movements and actions of your squad by
planning waypoints and giving specific
orders and
and press go to let your little dudes
execute your plan if it sounds tricky
that's because it is luckily you can
pause as you proceed through the mission
to change your plan on the fly if things
start to go awry with your original
tactics but if you can make the right
calls the criminal scum won't stand a
chance
let me know down in the comments if
you're keen to play battlefield hardline
or if there's another cops-and-robbers a
sort of game that gets your vote I'll
see you again next week